I promised Peter that I wouldn't do any
marketing in line with this very strict
and beautiful no [ __ ] policy that
there is in place here just forgive me
bear with me just two minutes because I
need to introduce you Muirfield just to
put you in the picture
what Muirfield does it's a bit of a
peculiar product we do web technology so
basically our technology our clients our
publishers so big newspapers and big
blobs they have like a presence online
and what our technology does is reading
the content and then present this
content into a mobile web the we built
so basically we are like renting our
mobile web to our tenants to our clients
why do they do that because this weather
has advanced you X so we have
functionality design we have swipe we
provide like this native experience that
normally a mobile web doesn't have we
provide a lot of speed meaning that our
webs load in like a tenth of the time or
a standard mobile web which turns into a
lot of extra traffic for them from
organic traffic and last but not least
we have a very sophisticated
monetization layer so basically we are
showing ads and we are selling the
advertisement space through programmatic
buying is anybody familiar here with
programmatic buying nobody - ok well
think about the stock market like so you
are on our website
you are like going down and scrolling
through this website and you are about
to see an ad the moment you are about to
see an ad that space goes on the market
in which several people bid and figure
out like how much they want to pay for
it and
in those fractional second we sell this
to the best offer so basically we are
capable of maximizing the value that you
reach from this advertisement space so I
joined Muirfield after living type form
after three years there I built the team
and the infrastructure over there and
then I thought it would be fun just to
restart over and do it again and one
enjoy Muirfield I found a bit of a shock
Muirfield is serving 4.2 billion ad
impression per month and this is a
corresponds to just around 700 million
visits because basically you have to sum
up all the visits from all the webs that
we manage and as Peter was saying it's
not just the scale of what we do there
is interesting but it's more like the
margins in programmatic buying are very
very small so this means that we cannot
possibly afford using the normal
technologies and the normal tools that
other company use I will give you an
example if we want to beget Google
Analytics 360 it will probably cost us
half a million and we want to scale in
the future you know so and it's not
doable so we would have to do that for
analytics we would have to do that for
our infrastructure we would have to do
that for the AFP or ad manager which is
Google advertisement platform we would
have to do that for all these different
tools so the operational cost will be
completely privative as a matter of fact
our competitors we had a few competitors
and they basically they don't exist
anymore because they all run out of
business because they couldn't manage
their costs so Muirfield is a company
that owes their success to their ability
of managing costs and this is like
extremely sensitive for us when I joined
this company so the result is that we
have to get many datasets from many
different places but these data sets
like the
not read in great shape you know we have
to do we have to get very very creative
at the time of overcoming the sampling
issues of Google Analytics at the time
of maybe crawling data from one place
because it's not available anywhere else
and so on and so on so the results of
that is a big mess we have like hundreds
of different data sets and each one of
them they come at different granularity
and each one of them that they need they
need to be consolidated and we have to
make sense of them therefore we have one
layer of complexity which is the scale
and another one which is the complexity
itself you still with me okay now that
is very interesting stuff like when I
joined the company I found that there
were extremely good software engineers
and so that then the in spite of not
having a department of data they had
done a lot of very hard work so we
already had collectors in place that
were reading data from all these
different data sources and all these
different partners that are involved in
the attack business and they were saving
them in a centralized repository
happened to be a MongoDB nobody's
perfect and then taken from there we
would have fit this data into a custom
build application that provides it to
the publishers because the publishers
have the same problem they have all this
data scattered everywhere so what we do
we can get creative again and we can try
to consolidate all this data and provide
it to them in such a way that is useful
furthermore what we do we give them the
option to connect to the Muirfield hub
and therefore they can give us their
data so they can connect us to their
Google Analytics that maybe has less
sampling than ours or they can put
upload data from different access piece
that we don't work with and this is
still adding more and more and more to
the complexity this is the tool that the
tool
the publishers can use for this purpose
it's neat it
all the big metrics it's as everything
is in his place but it's not really
quite flexible enough and MongoDB it's
hitting their limit and this is
something else that they did extremely
well I mean if they have a very
sophisticated alarm and monitor layer
and so if the revenue for a specific
website falls under a threshold they
would automatically open a JIRA to the
technical team to look into it or else
or if it's more like of a Content
problem like opener JIRA to a customer
success representative they can call the
client see what's going on so altogether
this is a lot more than I found in many
other company as a giant so don't tell
them like but I forum was a nightmare
when I joined them this guy's like one
much more I heard of it and so we have a
single source of truth there like when
we are looking at revenue we know this
revenue a discount from animosities and
we have these alerts and KPIs
we have somewhat of a data culture but
on the other hand there was a lot of
areas which I summarized there in terms
of the needle improvement like you know
they could have been they didn't have
enough flexibility they didn't have
access to all the metrics and especially
they had these very complex bits of data
all scattered all over the place and so
nobody could easily access them and get
a big picture
so before I start with diving into how
we resolve the problem I need to take a
moment to do a reflection of what really
is a data culture right and since I am a
lazy ass I only use this article here
that does the job for me so that I can
take all the credit and according to
these two very clever people there are
five building blocks to a data culture
none of them will surprise you like the
single sort of truth that we discussed a
data dictionary meaning that all the
metrics must be very well defined and
documented
broaden data access people must be able
to access this data and be sufficiently
literate as per understand it and lastly
they have to work all this in place you
need to freaking use it otherwise there
is no point previously I try to dust
this problem and I failed I failed
because I built a very beautiful
infrastructure but I failed to give
access real access to this data to the
people so I really wanted to focus at
Muirfield on this aspect and make sure
that whatever I was building people
could actually access it and there are
accessibility real data accessibility
means no barriers and the barriers come
into shapes number one technical
barriers for instance if you want to
access data in the data warehouse you
need to know SQL that's a technical
barrier the next level maybe you know
SQL but you need to learn how the data
is model another barrier still halfway
through and finally the worst one for
Marshall was the functional barrier I
mean even if you can access it you know
where this data is and you know SQL is
that is so complex and complex in model
that you can't expect anybody to know
all that except a few people in the
company where it is spend their day on
that data warehouse like reading in a
process in a reading at home still with
me yes so some assumption to make things
work worse there was like certain KPIs
which are the only ones that we can
report if I'm telling a customer that he
has a certain amount of visits this has
to match their own analytics visit
otherwise don't like to
are you talking about you're telling me
tenancy in 20 right and even worse the
revenue the only metric I can show them
are the metrics that match the revenue
that he's earning because that's the
metric and that's what this data here
they had very limited granularity so we
cannot really use it to do to learn
about it
hello good to see you granular data
granular access to the data requires
those tool that we cannot afford so
that's not looking good at all so
basically we ended up with this
implication we have high-level accurate
data that is fit for reporting but not
for analytics and then we have granular
approximated data which is great for
analytics but it's not fit for reporting
night-work some exploit in this data as
I was saying requires like a huge amount
of knowledge and I cannot expect my
stakeholders internal stakeholder a
marketing manager or a customer success
manager or monetization guide to learn
all that they will never will therefore
what to do no panic
we got options option number one is the
troop of data monkeys just get the back
and choose guys you put them there and
people ask them stuff and they are the
ones who know what happens so they just
go there and die and bring their back
and guess what they don't look happy
today and they're writing face you know
why because they hate your guts every
time you come to them and say hey I want
to know the churn rate on the guys that
look like this and data you don't tell
them why like if you want your data
scientists to run screaming out of the
door that's exactly what you have to do
so this option there is so much wrong
with it that I don't even want to start
forget it the next best thing to it is
the troop the army of BIA developers so
basically we are going to resolve all
these by building a huge quantity of
dashboards that's what we've done in
kinga that's what is done is of tonic to
cover all the different perspective why
we had to build 40 dashboard maybe how
long is that gonna take
and how long is that gonna cost and how
many people do I have to hire to do that
you know there was really not a very
sensitive option either so I didn't know
what to do
so let's fall back on the third option
and say there any technology well maybe
can help me resolve in this and this
technology eventually we decided to give
a go at look at while okay
are you familiar with lookup anybody not
as many as I would imagine okay
looker is bi it will just like click
view or just like tableau okay but it
has one important difference there is
that it has a logical layer like a model
logical model in which you can basically
pack all this information about how the
data is model and all the business rules
that you need to apply to calculate all
these KPIs and then a user would have
like a graphical interface that looks
like a pivot table and they can like
drag and drop concepts and what lucre is
doing is thanks to the information that
is stored in the model the right at the
SQL query for you and returns the data
this concept is nothing new actually
unfortunately I am old enough to know
that this kind of stuff there was I B M
Cognos there was best sap business
object before he was up there is
MicroStrategy all these people they were
doing this 15 years ago and then what
happened
that QlikView arrived and blew everybody
away
why because database is back then they
sucked donkey ass so you were there and
you were doing a query and you would
wait 20 minutes for your report to load
the big innovation of click is that they
would put everything in memory and so it
was going really really fast so what
happened all this kind of technology
that was like a building sequel for you
God became obsolete from night to day
a few years later what happened or big
data arrived and now it doesn't fit in
memory anymore and so now click view and
tableau doesn't scale and loads of
companies such as king for instance such
as of tonic such as well the one
dimension they find themselves with this
whole bunch of 40 dashboards they start
to go slow and they can't fit the data
into it anymore right meanwhile what
happened is that databases caught up
database event distributed so now we
have redshift was the big famous one now
we have snowflake we have the query we
have all this colored North databases
and now they're fast and so we went back
to 15 years ago but I the old vendor
from them they don't exist anymore like
so fortunately these people from Luca
were smart enough to see this
opportunity and they created this tool
that does that I looked into it and
whatever loved it really liked about it
is also that this modeling is code based
that is a language called look and L
which is this modeling language is quite
similar to SQL if you want that allows
you to model how the data is stored in
your data warehouse and to pack in their
information such as when you need to
calculate the number of customers you
exclude everybody who's got the new net
the domain formal field and then you add
these people and then you remove these
people so basically you can put in the
model all this information that is
required to supply the data the same
information that you cannot expect your
users to know a front still remain
yeah okay so I compared the looker where
the does this work yeah we click view
and we table and eventually I made this
choice look at the test like the only
thing is that it's not as fast of course
because it's pulling from the data from
the data warehouse and it's also that in
terms of visualization is not half as
powerful as tableau for instance now you
know sometimes it's just about deciding
what kind of problem you rather have and
to be honest I rather have this than
having users unable and incapable to
access my data I talk a lot right now
when once the sudden look at this
restricted me in my options to pick a
data warehouse because like there's all
this bunch of people and out of them we
isolated like the ones that were like
the best candidates now I'm happy to
tell you about the reason why all the
other ones were discarded but it's more
about the fact that oh they're not a
database but there are query engines or
else they are not distributed or else
they are extremely expensive and
corporate no and so what I did next I
compared my short list
there was a AWS redshift snowflake
bigquery and this very strange beast
called click house made in Russia and
kicks us it's very good as fast as hell
and it's open source and this is what I
found I'm not going to go through the
whole thing so the slides are available
for you to steal anytime but I'm gonna
look at a summary ratchet I use the
ratchet that deploy rafts they use it 3
years at iPhone it's a very good product
but it's got the best is that it works
it works and when it doesn't work
there's still quite a lot you can do to
tune it you know you
use distribution keys and you can sort
keys another but that's too big problems
like that the biggest one is probably
that it doesn't scale well in terms of
concurrency and when you open a look at
dashboard a look at dashboard is
basically running 20 queries at the same
time multiply this for 20 uses the sugar
in the company and you're gonna run out
I just heard from deliver oh for
instance that they had to move away from
received from this very specific reason
and then the second problem the receive
has is that computing storage are
coupled meaning that if you want more
space you need to buy more nodes and
more nodes and more nodes in a scenario
in which you have a lot of cool data
you're gonna end up purchasing space and
space and space and a lot of computation
that should not actually need because
the data that you want to process is
only the most recent one and lastly it
worries maybe is a shift because it's
the same product it was in 2013 and I
start to see many things in terms of
functionality that don't quite cut it
anymore
bigquery
we are friends with Google Muirfield
contributed most of the Google amp
project so finger very few people know I
didn't know either and it's fully
managed scales linearly and it has these
very nice in terms of functionality is
quite good it has a lot of stuff so
everybody is telling me speaking very
highly about it what I didn't like first
of all is the pricing model so you pay
per query so imagine your analysts right
I goes there is greenies analysis and
you're writing a sequel there and when
you finish the query and you're about to
press start you see a $45 you're right
you know and maybe you forgot a comma
and you have to spend another 45 and
as now that we want we are doing this
for people to use it as much as possible
so basically the incentive is going the
wrong way around I didn't like that
Google provides you with some flat rate
pricing but that starts at a very high
amount of money Tony Favreau tab area at
least 10k per month and this is in
Muirfield word is completely reasonable
and then also it reminded me dangerously
of Hadoop in hive feels quite like
clunky with all these moving parts and
you know and coming from King that we
had this Hadoop cluster with 315 nodes
and was like broken every second day I
was I got used to rush if that is just
work and I really didn't want to go back
there the next option is a clique house
this is super interesting because it's
open source it's made by the people from
Yandex in Russia it's supposedly the
fastest corner date database on the
market this is like it's unreal it came
very well recommended by some very
extremely good brands I think New Relic
are using it if I remember well so it's
very good and like processing huge
amount of data and doing aggregation in
a very short time the doubt that we have
is the ANA was a clever now confused the
problem is that it's high maintenance
because it's open sewers so basically
you're gonna have to have a team de to
maintain it so I had some doubts over
like the actual total cost of ownership
you know you don't pay license but then
how much have you paid to maintain it
and even if it was cheaper maybe we
don't need to process that amount of
data because we still have a big
elasticsearch cluster that we can use to
do some of the heavy lifting in all the
logs and all the kind of stuff
and then it has like this very
non-standard sequel it looks like very
Cody and especially what he had that put
me off is that didn't support well look
at didn't support it right and the plot
introduced apart just a few weeks back
which makes it interesting so this is
like an option that I wouldn't discard
it's only there is a little more of a
high-maintenance option for you and
lastly I discover snowflake kaboom so
first time I discovered snowflake I I
heard what they were promising in I
didn't believe a word of it I saw what
it does the super interesting is that
supposedly separates analysis actually
separate storage and computing all the
literature store in there is gonna cost
you as much as storing it in s3 cost you
20 terabytes $20 per terabyte per month
which is very very little so if you have
a lot of cool data you can leave it in
snowflake leave it in s3 and it's the
same and his super cool secondly it has
a type of storage which is a variant
type and this variant will accept JSON
will accept XML and in sequel within the
tool it has like save the sequel
functions that can do very very advanced
processing on this JSON data to like
explode it and summarize it and change
in shape and edit it you can do a lot of
operations of JSON they go way beyond
the operations that you can do in Hadoop
and way beyond the ones you can do in
bigquery lastly where you have to
process data you fire up a virtual
warehouse that is just a computing unit
that is probably an easy to machine and
you just pay for the minute or what
you're using one thing that is super
interesting is the scales linearly so
basically if I have a query to run I can
take a small machine that cost me $3 an
hour and maybe will take me
our and I spent three dollars or else I
can take a machine that is ten time
beggars is gonna cost me $30 an hour but
is gonna take me ten times less six
minutes and so my total cost will be
still three dollars I couldn't believe
my eyes
so I can take this monster machines and
take like five hours query and make them
run in ten minutes
and I pay the same turns out it's true
and so far we tried it and skills
linearly maybe not quite linear Lieber
linearly SH you can Sarah and so there
it has a lot of very advanced the
functionality compared to R a shift and
on top of it it shares the same dialect
they just like copy pasted the dialect
from redshift so any query from redshift
will probably run in snowflake they
don't pay me I promise
right it's just that I'm very
enthusiastic because like it seemed
ready to check all the boxes
the only doubts that I had back then
were in terms of performance and in
terms of costs lastly for the ETL layer
we decided to go for a passion flow and
we decided to go alt this is interesting
because like air flow is an extremely
sophisticated and flexible scheduler and
you can use it for anything you can also
use it to process data if you want but
if you use it to process data the
complexity scales you know and it's more
difficult and then you'll have to go
distributing and you have to do a lot of
things but if you just in just your data
you use it to pull your data ingest it
in snowflake and then you let us know if
like do all the heavy lifting then it
becomes a very interesting option
because it's free is flexible it has a
lot of functionality in water flow
management there's a big community
support in
and it's quite easy to to deploy what
quiet it's not really the easiest but
it's okay I mean two of my guys they set
it up in a couple of weeks and it works
like a charm
so I were a little commander flow so
this is the result in architecture as
you can see there is the bits of the top
which is the same ones that were dug
from before we still use in them and I
just like created this layer underneath
so we are using air flow to take all
this data we put it in a ratchet sorry
we put it in snowflake and then we
process it with this virtual warehouses
and we can use a virtual warehouse for
the ETL another virtual warehouse for
local and the thing is that it really
seems that this virtual warehouse they
handle concurrency beautiful you can
have like 10 different warehouses which
are the computing unit by the way you
can it have ten different computing unit
accessing the same data and so far it
seems like it handles it beautifully I
don't know how they do it but here it is
seems to work I still have segments
there in the in the picture but I'm
trying I'm going to get rid of it as
soon as possible because at our scale is
not convenient enough
I love segments if I had like small data
I would love I would of dual segment
well right now it's kind of redundant
and we only use it because it's very
convenient to send like low volume data
to certain integration such as
Salesforce and stuff like that but the
Sun stage will disappear I'm almost on
a-- and before proceeding though we had
to buy we had this in mind before
proceeding we have to validate that Luca
would actually work at resolving all
this complexity that we had in our data
and we had to go to validate that
snowflake would handle this the volumes
will be sufficiently good in thermal
performance and
specially against again in terms of cost
so we created the small proper concept
which we took a few of the our main data
sources and we fed them into snowflake
in the form of raw Jason's not
processing when we are in snowflake we
did the processing and we created this
looker model right just a tiny bit of
marketing because I'm very grateful for
these guys from sis consultant there are
small consultancy company in Barcelona
and they are a good local partner and
they were like extremely helpful for
with us and they didn't even charge us
you know like if you're gonna plan to
use a looker I would recommend you to
call them or contact me I will make you
an intro and then we we created these a
couple of dashboards we look up and we
put it in front of our users all of
these was very quicker I mean it just
took us probably a month since we
figured out what we had to do to execute
it like the POC took like a month more
or less so and you can get a trial for a
both a snowflake and looker for a month
so you can try it out for free so this
is the final result what you're looking
at here the data stake is like more or
less the same data that you saw at the
beginning and we were providing to our
users like the custom build the solution
Murphy had made but is done with looker
and is pulling from snowflake and the
difference is that once I'm here and I
have all my main metrics up here and I
have all my breakdown by a website here
what I can do is like I can click on a
website and that is going to bring me
through another dashboard that is
analyzing that specific tenant and here
I have each one of these charts is
possibly coming from different data
sources is possibly like we have like
dimensions and metrics that are
aggregated differently where it's like a
Holy Mass but people don't really need
to know about that just like drag the
thing and the model takes care of it
underneath so and what I like even more
of that is that you can click here and
say explore from here and what you'll
access is basically the the chart
underneath and this is the data
underneath what you are looking at the
scandal like pivot table in Excel so
from here users can create this chart
modified it on the can create their own
and then build their own dashboard then
think about it data governance is
centralized they cannot [ __ ] it up they
cannot create metrics that don't make
sense they cannot create like I'd say
the ARPU is twice as much as what it
should be no because like you know all
the processing is governed by the data
model underneath the logical model and
all the data is the one in in snowflake
in the data warehouse they have very
little room for screwing it up so there
is it before I live in I always like to
show this light which is the one that my
boss doesn't like me to show and it's
like looking back at their obey these
are like this last seven years of my
life and it's super interesting to see
how the landscape changed like you know
in 2012 we had sequel server and I was
doing a great job back then and we were
starting to use Hadoop we were using
Pentaho data integration for ETL I used
it a lot you can still use it is still
good for certain things and then we
moved on to King in 2014 and it had
evolved so much like you know it held
disappeared and we were doing everything
in Java we were using mostly Hadoop and
axle solar was one of the first coroner
databases then they migrated to by
querying
and then they had click view and which
then broke for the reasons I told you
before and they moved on to looker in
2006 a join 16 I joined i-4 and that's
crazy like three years ago I created an
infrastructure from scratch and three
years later I created a new wondrous
nothing to do with it like a completely
different technology this suck this
stuff is moving so fast and right now
what I'm doing is this is super
interesting right now most of our data
sources are api's and micro services
which makes tools such as Pentaho quite
obsolete because they don't handle it
very well
ETL is done in Python with air flow and
the data warehouse a snowflake and the
BI layer is Luka
and God knows what's coming next
exciting times thank you very much for
not falling asleep do you provide access
to looker for your external users and if
so do you have any solution for a role
level data access security or not we
don't do that yet but it is definitely
something we are considering and yes
there is pretty simple ways you can
handle row level security and also
snowflake offers a data sharing service
in case you want to share the data
directly from the database since it's
like a sauce
you know people can just connect and
download it from there yes definitely a
good option your concerns with bigquery
seems quite soft as compared to the hard
concerns of like not having analytic
functions or whatever one of the
advantages have being charged for the
amount of data at standards you get to
really optimize the cost if you can be
smart by how you write the queries
given that cost seems to be something
that you care quite a lot about at my
field I would have thought that the
bigquery pricing model would actually
appeal to your team because you can be
really you can really kind of optimize
that that query spend so I'm kind of
slightly surprised that you actually got
off by that yeah basically I completely
agree with you that you just pay for
what you use so you can really optimize
that what I don't like about it is that
it's unpredictable I really don't know
what kind of queries people will use and
especially what bothers me is the
counter incentive to do queries and
doing this so that people do as many
queries as possible so what really put
me off was the fact that you are about
to run a query you see this price tag
$100 and it feels like a lot maybe
you're not gonna run it I mean you're
gonna run half of them you know so the
incentive was going the other way in the
case of snowflake when I was talking
about these computing units they also
charge you by the minute but they charge
you by the minute that the warehouse is
in use regardless of how many queries go
through it so you can say I'm fire in a
medium size warehouse for my analysts
and I know that is gonna cost me a very
words if it's always on $6 per hours so
6 by 8 48 50 quid per day okay that's my
budget I feel comfortable that it cannot
go beyond that and I feel comfortable
that my analyst will be more than happy
to pull as many query as they want
you
[Music]